imagine what would happen if everything
connected to the internet suddenly
stopped working
hospitals wouldn't be able to access
their records tests would take far
longer to process and thousands of
people would die because they can't get
help quickly enough all the atms in the
world would suddenly go offline and if
people want to withdraw money they will
have to stand in line at the bank and
banks would quickly run out of cash on
hand what do you mean the bank is out of
money
cctv and security cameras managed
wirelessly would go down leading to even
more crime automated toll gates wouldn't
work anymore causing massive traffic
jams google amazon facebook all these
companies were shut down leaving
hundreds of thousands of people without
jobs air travel would be disrupted as
airlines figure out how to go back to
old flight plan systems satellites and
gps would be useless nuclear reactors
would go unmonitored the stock market
would crash and the world would descend
into absolute chaos
thankfully a global internet outage
isn't possible right it could never
happen in a developed country america
has to have loads of failsafes in place
to stop the internet from going
downright well here's the thing we
really don't no one does
[Music]
a series of cyber attacks that have just
been launched in ukraine atms shut down
in kiev that petya provided a similar
ransom message but it was never intended
to provide a fix
its goal was purely destructive
june 17 2017 it's a quiet tuesday
afternoon in ukraine seemingly out of
nowhere something goes wrong with the
internet
starting in kiev almost every electronic
device connected to the internet goes
down and is quickly spread throughout
the rest of the country there's
obviously one prime suspect that's on
people's minds the us government tonight
is urgently warning that someone they're
not saying who uh but presumably russia
in ukraine cyber attacks from russia
aren't anything new but no one has ever
seen something at this scale before
chernobyl's nuclear plant went offline
atm stopped working no one could pay for
gas packages and mail got lost with lots
of them never being found again wherever
something was connected to the internet
a telltale ransomware message was
displayed the price to get access to
your computer or phone back 300 in
bitcoin
but here's the thing even if you paid
you never got your data back
this wasn't just an ordinary reservoir
attack this was a political move by
russia they weren't going for maximum
destruction they weren't trying to make
money from ukraine oh no the point of
this cyber attack from russia was to
convey one thing we're inside your
electric grid and we can bring down your
entire country at any moment
the official said a wave of so-called
denial of services attacks struck around
4 pm ukraine time and among the reported
victims are banks and government
websites 80 of ukraine's computers were
wiped clean in the attack but it didn't
stop there
any company that did business in ukraine
that employed ukrainians remotely or
even touched ukraine with a six-foot
pole was under attack too everything
from fedex the cadbury to pfizer was
affected by what eventually became known
as the not pieta malware
and less than 24 hours the russian
hackers who perpetrated the attack
inflicted over 10 billion dollars in
damages
and this was in a country that wasn't
completely reliant on the internet
in ukraine baby monitors insulin pumps
stove cars pacemakers weren't web
enabled yet meaning that they could
still work without being connected to
the internets and that was their saving
grace even with the internet down people
could still survive
but what would happen in a country where
every device relies on the internet
we're electric cars smart homes are just
a part of everyday life
a country like america
and one of the things that makes this
such a challenging problem is
all you need is one weak link
an attack of this magnitude would cause
death destruction and anarchy on a scale
never seen before all without firing a
single bullet or dropping a single bomb
it would spark the next great generation
of warfare warfare that is extremely
different from what we've grown
accustomed to
but obviously america is prepared for
something like this right i mean we're
talking about ukraine versus america the
country with the most military spending
ever
well not really because here's the thing
for decades america has only been
focusing on the offensive side of cyber
warfare like china and russia the us has
been developing teams of hackers with
some of the best skills in the world but
none of them are focusing on defending
our internet systems which has pretty
much left the world right back to where
it was during the cold war where every
superpower has weapons of mass
destruction and the only reason they
don't use them on each other is because
they know the other side will retaliate
except these wmds don't rely on nuclear
fission or the like but ones and zeros
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team and this is how the
world will end
[Music]
public is a social investing app trusted
by millions where you can easily invest
in stocks etfs and crypto with any
amount of money public is a serious game
changer because you can follow other
investors right in the app to see what
they invest in just think about how much
of an advantage you could have by
getting to peer into the brains of these
successful people by seeing exactly what
they're investing in and i'm also in
public you can follow me at jake tran
public has thousands of stocks and etfs
to choose from and over 30 different
cryptos like bitcoin ethereum and doge
you can buy little slices of a stock etf
or crypto instead of a full share so it
is accessible no matter what your
investment budget is the public app is
also free and there are no commissions
on standard stock trades and unlike
other investment apps out there public
puts its investors first they never sell
your trades to market makers and instead
your trades are routed directly to the
exchanges plus public is backed by big
name investors like will smith the
chainsmokers and tony hawk and if you go
to public.com and create an account
you'll get a free stock worth anywhere
from three to a thousand dollars that's
public.com to get a free stock with the
link below thanks to public for
sponsoring this
[Music]
happened video months ago when a very
sophisticated virus infected computers
in the saudi arabian state oil company
august 15 2012 the day before a major
saudi arabian religious holiday 1108 am
someone accesses saudi's state-owned oil
companies computers and carries out one
of the most destructive acts of computer
sabotage they have ever experienced
aramco's entire computer network is
infected with a virus that erases at
least 75 percent of its data emails
documents files spreadsheets everything
and replaces all of it with a picture of
a burning american flag
aramco supplies around 10 of all the
world's oil supply and an attack like
that could have ripple effects all
across the world but how did someone
access a computer network as secure as
one of the world's most important oil
companies
by using the most powerful weapon in any
hacker's cyber arsenal a zero day
zero days are basically like the weapons
of the cyber arms race when you're
coding a piece of software you're bound
to leave a trail of tiny little mistakes
miss a comma or type a capital o instead
of zero and the vulnerability that
creates might be enough for a hacker to
exploit your software these are zero
days
they're bugs bits of code any sort of
vulnerability that lets you exploit a
computer network software program pretty
much anything that's on a computer or
connected to the internet they're little
security holes and software that no one
knows about yet think about them like a
hole or a tunnel in a border wall that
border patrol doesn't know about yet but
the minute that exploit is taken
advantage of the border patrol will
patch up that whole or tunnel and then
you can't use that zero day anymore
almost every software or computer
program in the world has at least one
zero day that no one knows about so if
you're an intelligence agency government
or dictator your goal is to find these
zero days before anyone else does and
save them for a rainy day when the time
comes to exploit a zero day you need to
make sure you inflict as much damage as
possible gather as much intel as
possible before the exploit is found and
patched up we're talking hacking into
databases shutting down electricity
grids gaining control of nuclear
reactors the ideas are endless the only
problem was zero days aren't exactly
easy to find you need a lot of coding
expertise and a lot of man-hours so even
though zero days were incredibly
valuable and dangerous in the beginning
they kind of stayed under the radar
right until idefense was created the
first company in the world to buy and
sell zero days and it marked the
beginning of a new arms race but instead
of a nuclear arms race it was a cyber
one
[Music]
the notorious hacking group anonymous
has declared war on russia we've seen
the attacks on wall street over the last
six months grow significantly their call
to fight in the cyberspace has resulted
in a lot of websites not being available
some websites going down we cannot look
back years from now and wonder why we
did nothing in the face of real threats
to our security and our economy
it was 2003 and i defense was a failing
tech company that desperately needed to
find its niche after all this was right
after the dot-com bubble burst
life wasn't exactly easy for tech and
internet companies trying to make a name
for themselves so idefense decided to
tap into the one industry that was
booming the zero day black market you
see dictatorships and criminal
organizations didn't have the manpower
or the skills to find and exploit zero
days themselves so they turned to black
hat hackers the hackers that did illegal
stuff like creating ransomware viruses
and ddos attacks that targeted everyone
from cnn to amazon back then no one had
really realized the true potential of
zero days and they were being sold for
dirt sheep so i defense saw an
opportunity buy zero days for popular
company software from these black hat
hackers and then sell it back to these
software companies so they can fix the
vulnerabilities i defense became an
instant hit they would buy zero days for
75 dollars each from hackers all over
the world then they get their team to
make sure the zero day was completely
legit and set up a presentation on how
it could be used by criminals if a
company subscribed to their services
this zero date and all the extra info
will be handed over to that company so
they could fix it
idefense's business plan was so
successful that in just a year's time
the original subscription fee of
eighteen thousand dollars had more than
doubled and for particularly vulnerable
companies a subscription could cost
nearly half a million dollars a year
that's how much these zero days were
worth to companies who could lose
millions or billions of dollars from one
vulnerability
but then just like every super popular
niche market other organizations started
getting in on the game idefense was no
longer alone and the race to find zero
days was on for both white hat and black
hat reasons
[Music]
[Music]
government agencies and tech companies
had gotten smart about zero days now
they saw the danger and potential so
just like every other business they
wanted to bypass the middleman so
companies like microsoft started going
to hackers directly offering the exact
same deal eye defense did realizing how
much their zero days were really worth
hackers started hoarding all the bugs
and vulnerabilities they could hoping
for a massive payday from the right
person and all the government agencies
well the nsa and cia decided to get in
on the game themselves too they set up
massive cyber departments with the sole
focus of collecting zero days for
everything from apple to banks to online
messaging platforms they said it was all
in the name of national security but the
truth was these agencies weren't really
helping companies fix their security
systems instead they were using them to
spy on the public and it wasn't just
america security agencies all over the
world were following the us's example
boarding and building up a cyber weapons
arsenal ready to be used at the tap of a
button they had just overlooked one
small but essential detail the
globalization of tech industries
[Music]
um and that three decades ago there
really wasn't this moral hazard baked in
because
if we found a hole in huawei software
well for the most part americans weren't
using huawei
but china was and north korea was and
iran and sudan and syria so we had a
legitimate case to make that we should
break into that software and use it as a
beach head
to spy on some of our adversaries but
these days three decades later and
huawei is obviously a great exception
and we're lobbying hard to get our
allies not to use huawei's hardware and
software and 5g but
you know
with few exceptions we're all using the
same technology now the government did
its best zero-day work just as the world
experienced another tech boom for years
the cia and nsa have been finding holes
in foreign tech companies like huawei
and samsung and using them to spy on
people they thought were a threat to
america but by the 2010s these companies
weren't just selling to their own people
anymore they were selling their tech on
a global scale so now it wasn't just the
chinese or north koreans america could
spy on it was any american using a
huawei or samsung phone it was anyone on
earth using a piece of technology the us
intel agencies had found zero days for
and the rest of the world well they were
just as happy to use their own zero days
to spy on the americans who were using
their tech and with all of this zero day
hoarding the world faced a new problem
extremely vulnerable software that no
one wanted to fix
america wasn't about to tell apple about
a zero day they found that would mean
apple fixes the issue and the nsa or
cia's access gets cut so they kept their
findings a secret
big mistake you see with so many
vulnerabilities in u.s companies and no
one to identify or fix them it left
america open for attack
and that attack came in august 2016.
[Music]
a group calling themselves the shadow
brokers claim that they've hacked the
nsa according to foreignpolicy.com
a mysterious group of hackers known only
as the shadow brokers announced their
hack on twitter their target
the nsa
in the leaks that followed dozens of the
nsa's most secret and advanced cyber
weapons were sold to the highest bidder
it was an embarrassment in national
security catastrophe the nsa was
supposed to be the guys protecting
america against hackers in zero days and
yet they were pretty much the first ones
to fall victim to it
even worse most of the hacking tools the
shadow brokers had stolen had actually
been used for 14 months before their
twitter announcement and no one at the
nsa had realized anything was wrong that
was the power of zero days the nsa has
not commented on this because they're
again like any government agency they're
not going to confirm or deny
and the worst part america the country
that's supposed to be at the forefront
of fighting against these hacks had been
caught completely off guard and as far
as anyone can see even after the leak
the nsa and all the other us agencies
are still nowhere near securing their
cyber weapons arsenals
[Music]
yes
the cost of cyber attacks
uh is now now far exceeds the cost of
terrorism even some of the most
conservative
estimates um far exceed the cost of
terrorism but we haven't really opened
our eyes we are all in each other's
grids at this point okay i've reported
that you know we are in russia's grid
they are in ours
we are doing it as sort of a show of
mutually assured destruction but we are
all awaiting that geopolitical trigger
for anyone to actually shut off the
lights and i don't think anyone actually
wants to do it
because we would just turn around and do
it right back
this is our reality there are hackers
all over the world collecting zero days
on everything from disney plus to the
department of defense the world's tech
has become so globalized that america's
agencies are in everyone else's networks
which means russia and china are also in
america's networks too basically the
whole world is right back in the days of
nuclear acceleration when everyone was
rushing to create the biggest baddest
nuclear weapons to try to scare other
countries from attacking them no one is
focusing on defense or de-escalation
everyone is just trying to out-develop
the other side so that if one country
gets the guts to attack all of the
others will be ready to retaliate
immediately and if everything carries on
the way it is now we may end up in cyber
armageddon widespread blackouts nuclear
reactors overtaken pipelines shut down
entire economies will be brought to a
standstill all from the push of a button
and panic will ensue
when the cyber arms race first started
america was in the middle of another
fight the war on terror see on the night
special forces assassinated america's
most feared enemy osama bin laden in his
compound they discovered something
drastic a treasure trove of computers
hard drives notebooks and printed files
lying around on every floor these files
could contain priceless intelligence and
if they left it for the pakistani
military the sama's compound was in
pakistan they may never get their hands
on it again so they radioed back to
their commanders asking for as much time
as they could spare they gave them an
extra 10 minutes ultimately the seals
were able to stretch it to 18 minutes
and in that 18 minutes came a treasure
trove of 500 000 digital and physical
files this intel collection would become
known as the bin laden papers
and for years most of those files were
kept classified but in 2017 the cia
finally declassified over 470 000 of
those files for the world to see and
what they contained was a complete
revelation these files showed a whole
new side of osama bin laden that the
world had never seen before but here's
the thing a video that goes this deep
into bin laden's life his attacks and
his plans for the world is basically
guaranteed to get demonetized so that's
why we just released a brand new private
documentary going over the bin laden
papers in all its infamy the channel
members have been loving the documentary
all you have to do to get access to this
documentary right now and all the other
documentary length videos that are too
controversial too dark too risky to post
publicly is to click the join button
below once you sign up you'll get
exclusive access to the bin laden papers
plus others efforty jepsteen monsanto
the company that owns the world's food
supply mk ultra and many more in the
future these are the things they should
be teaching you in university about how
the world works but unlike university
you get all of this for just five
dollars a month and what's even better
is that if you join and you don't think
it's worth it email me and i'll
personally refund you the money pause
the video and click that join button
below right now
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
make documentaries just like this one
every single week on money power and
crime multiple times a week for free so
if you enjoyed this one click that
subscribe button below remember you can
always dislike and unsubscribe whenever
you want so you have nothing to lose and
everything to gain if you want longer
documentaries that are too controversial
to post publicly click that join button
below we just put out a documentary on
the bin laden papers basically the
secret life of bin laden that was
reviewed by a bunch of declassified
documents that was seized during the
raid that killed bin laden super
fascinating video that would definitely
get them monetized because it talks
about bin laden and 911 all the things
youtube doesn't like and you can watch
it right now by clicking that join
button below there's a refund policy too
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it just email me and i'll
personally refund you the money no
problem that's going to wrap it up thank
you so much for watching stay dangerous
out there and i'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
you